le numérique est omniprésent dans notre
vie en dix ans
il est temps 30
aussi formidable qui puisse être il est
porteur d'un vent de changement qui
transforme nos sociétés et c'est cette
raison qui m'amène aujourd'hui avec vous
afin de vous partager ma réflexion
personnelle qui a démarré il ya trois
ans de cela déjà vous partager ma vision
j'insiste et mes expériences dans un but
très très simple vous sensibiliser aux
aspects positifs négatifs du numérique
afin que vous deveniez tous des acteurs
majeurs du changement et pour par les
changements et numérique
j'ai sélectionné trois aspects dont je
voudrais vous faire part le premier ça
l'aspect économique
croyez-moi si j'écris c'est pas pour moi
c'est pour vous nous pourrions parler
des banques en ligne d accès à distance
il en aurait pas un grand changement non
le réel bouleversement est amené par les
monnaies virtuelles
j'étais à votre place il y a huit ans de
cela
dans cet iut quand ils ont entendu
parler pour la première fois du bitcoin
à l'époque c'était la première monnaie
virtuelle qui avait été créée en 2008
deux ans avant d'arriver à lutter et 11
ans plus tard en 2009 aujourd'hui à les
valoriser un big n est valorisée plus de
10000 euros et nous dénombrons plus de
2000 monnaie virtuelle rassembleur et
même plus simple de créer sa propre
monnaie virtuelle que les ouvrir un
compte en banque aujourd'hui
et là on a encore des nouveaux acteurs
qui arrivent sur le marché
facebook va démarrer sa nouvelle monnaie
virtuelle qui s'appelle libra et ils ont
pour objectif d'ici 2021 de faire des
accords avec des entreprises du secteur
bancaire comme par exemple visa ou
mastercard afin de permettre à toutes
les personnes selon leur plan qui ont un
téléphone portable
donc tout le monde ici j'imagine d'avoir
accès à de l'argent sans forcément avoir
un accès à un compte bancaire
est ce que vous imaginez les impacts que
cela pourrait avoir
s'ils nous font radicalement le système
bancaire et que nous connaissons si
demain on se passe complètement des
banques
le deuxième aspect bouleversé par le
numérique c'est l'aspect culturel
assez lisible et pour parler de l'aspect
culturel de ce changement là je vais
prendre l'exemple de la chine puisqu'il
faut bien comprendre que le numérique
est mondiale et que les décisions prises
par un pays vont forcément impacter des
autres qui ici a entendu parler du seul
crédit de systèmes ya du monde c'est
bien en français on va traduire sa part
système de notes sociale des habitants
parce que là j'ai plus de monde qui
connaît ouais ouais c'est mon accent qui
pourrissent et ça ok ce système là
leur but est de permettre d'affecter une
note social à chaque habitant chinois
l'idée est très simple c'est que en
fonction de cette note
vous avez accès à différents types ou
qualité de service qui vous donne accès
bah justement peut-être des promotions
des nouveaux lotissements immobiliers
des avantages sensationnel il faut avoir
conscience que eux ils ont démarré ce
déploiement que ce test depuis 2014
et quand je pense qu'en europe ça fait
un ou deux ans qu'on entend parler avec
ça ça entraîne un changement culturel
énorme
j'ai vu récemment un témoignage sur
internet deux personnes nous montrait en
direct que ce foyer voyait refuser
l'achat d'un billet d'avion à cause de
leurs notes social trop faible vous
imaginez vous ne pouvez plus sortir du
pays
si votre vie sociale n'est pas assez
élevé c'est incroyable il faut bien
comprendre que ça a des conséquences
culturelles énorme ça va ça va avoir des
conséquences culturelles incroyable et
je suis persuadé que d'autres pays
suivront l'exemple par la suite le
troisième aspect dont il faut parler et
l'aspect moral
et pour cet aspect je vais prendre deux
cas concrets qui vont vous amis à des
questions d'éthique avec de
l'intelligence artificielle
le premier nous concerne directement en
france récemment 2019
nous avons déployé un nouveau système de
détection de fraude fiscale
alors peut-être que vous n'êtes pas
encore concerné qui a permis à l'état de
récupérer deux fois plus d'argent qu'en
2018 en neuf mois seulement
donc c'est super on ne peut plus
fraudées et ils veulent encore aller
plus loin ils veulent agréger les
données des réseaux sociaux facebook
instagram twitter peut-être que facebook
pour vous c'est plus vraiment réseau
social mais pour moi ma génération
c'était le numéro un et vérifiez que vos
déclarations concorde avec ce que vous
avez posté comme photo pour caricaturer
une personne déclarant le smic voyage
aux bahamas serait un potentiels
fraudeurs
vous pouvez comprendre les dérives que
cela peut avoir
si on ne se pose pas les bonnes
questions le deuxième exemple que je
vais prendre ça concerne les voitures
autonomes qui ici a déjà vu des voitures
autonomes très bien parfait pour ceux
qui savent pas vous en voyez beaucoup à
san francisco et ses deux voitures comme
les autres avec plein de capteurs autour
et elle se conduisent toute seules la
seule contrainte c'est d'avoir encore
une personne au volant qui ne touchent
pas me keita pour des besoins de lego
vous avez ces voitures qui se promène
dans les rues un peu partout mais je
vais vous poser cette question
imaginez vous êtes tranquille au volant
de votre voiture autonome flambant neuf
est là un accident mortel est inévitable
ça peut arriver
et cet accident
causerait la mort d'une personne
laquelle on devrait sauver vous si vous
étiez au volant de votre voiture que
vous conduisez vous aurez à l'instinct
instinctivement vous sauverez la vie je
pense
on est tous programmés comme ça la
voiture elle elle est programmée
différemment la voiture à la des
probabilités à la un algorithme et elle
peut suivre
elle peut prendre une décision qui nous
paraît très irrationnel mais qui selon
elle est totalement logique
sur quels critères on devrait se baser
alors l'âge le sexe le salaire le nombre
de personnes dans la voiture faisant des
questions auxquelles nous devons
forcément trouver des réponses
j'ai pas pris ces trois aspects au
hasard un bouleversement majeur d'ordre
économique culturelle et morale entraîne
ce que l'on appelle une révolution
oui nous sommes et nous continuons
d'aller dans ce qu'on appelle une
révolution numérique
nous sommes face à des bouleversements
sans précédent qui a impacté les
sociétés et comme toute révolution
elle a deux visages que je vais vous
présenter avec cinq catégories
particulières la première l'emploi le
numérique est formidable et a permis la
création d'un grand nombre d'emplois
j'en suis le premier exemple je suis
développeur 100 numérique n'aurait
peut-être pas eu de travail
ça facilite sa facilité également
grandement le travail de toutes les
personnes qui sont dans un bureau je
pense que vous en connaissez au moins
tous
leur travail a été signifiée
significativement améliorée avec la mise
en place du numérique
d'un autre côté en france c'est près de
42 % des emplois qui sont menacés avec
la robotisation et l'automatisation
je pense que vous le voyez au quotidien
quand vous faites vos courses au
supermarché vous avez de plus en plus de
caisses automatiques
il faut avoir conscience à ces métiers
là nous les voyons et je pense que
certains peuvent être un peu dérangée de
voir justement ces caisses automatiques
remplacer certains métiers il faut avoir
conscience que les industriels ça fait
des années déjà que leur
sont menacés voire remplacer ou
transformés avec le numérique on est
donc en droit de demander dans ce cas là
si numérique à plus d'impact positif que
négatif et quelles solutions pouvons
nous trouver pour répondre à ces
ajustements la deuxième catégorie
l'information ou la la j'ai très très
mal écrit
prenons l'exemple de wikipédia vous y
avez tous accès peu importe où vous êtes
et vous avez accès à une base de
connaissances incroyable tout le monde
peut contribuer l'enrichir et vous
accédez à ce que vous voulez où vous
voulez comme vous voulez pour vous aider
à vous représenter wikipédia imaginons
qu'on imprime alors ça vous paraît
peut-être aberrant mais quelqu'un l'a
fait en quelqu'un s'amuse à le faire en
version anglaise uniquement wikipedia
faut savoir que c'est quand même dans
des dizaines dizaine de langues
si on imprime et wikipedia forme version
anglaise format encyclopédies et qu'on
empile est tous les livres on aurait une
pile qui ferait la moitié de la hauteur
de la tour eiffel et les 91 promis
premier livre c'est uniquement porter
des matières ce que vous imaginez cela
sans nuire et qu'est ce que vous
imaginez une contribution pareil sans le
numérique est ce qu'on pourra voir une
telle base de connaissance aujourd'hui
dans autant de langues
je pense pas que cela aurait été
possible dans l'autre côté l'effectif
vont bon train chacun essaie d'attirer
des sur son blog avec des sujets un peu
de buzz référence enfin forcément des
sources fiables nous internautes devant
être plus en plus vigilants quant à
l'information qu'on lit si on n'est pas
si on ne fait pas attention on pourrait
très bien propager une nouvelle qui est
complètement erronée on perd on a de
moins en moins confiance même si
internet se veut ouvert il faut qu'on
reste vigilant c'est indispensable
3e catégorie l'éducation
encore une fois je pense que dans vos
études vous avez tous accès au numérique
et vous l'utilisez tous aujourd'hui
n'importe quelle personne avec un
téléphone ou un ordinateur une connexion
internet peut avoir accès à des cours en
ligne des diplômes qui cursus
universitaire tout ça depuis chez soi et
même des cours qui sont à l'étranger
alors vous n'êtes pas encore concerné on
les perd conscience vous êtes bien ici
où vous êtes
mais je pense que dans plusieurs années
vous pourrez si vous voulez suivre les
cours du hem haïti où des cours d école
en inde ce genre de choses tout ça grâce
au numérique
imaginez que vous voulez suivre un
nouveau cursus il faille aller en inde
ce serait tout de suite mais en pratique
c'est formidable pour toutes les
personnes qui sont en reconversion
professionnelle
ça leur donne accès à les nouveaux
diplômes on en parlait justement tout à
l'heure et des nouvelles formations et
des nouvelles possibilités
en contrepartie on constate que les nuls
numérique est parfois utilisé en excès
dans l'éducation surtout celle de nos
enfants
une personne de mon entourage qui est
professeur des coques et pardon
directrice d'école maternelle mais
affirmé qu'elle voyait une différence
significative entre l'intégration
d'enfants ayant accès aux tablettes et
aux téléphones et ceux pour qui ces
objets ont été interdits il est urgent
crucial de sensibiliser les parents aux
impacts que peut avoir le numérique sur
le développement de leur enfant
la quatrième catégorie
c'est la vitesse ordinateurs tablettes
smartphones tout au plus puissant de
plus en plus rapide je pense que vous
voyez au quotidien vous avez grandi avec
les objets et vous avez réellement senti
une différence entre les premières
versions que vous aviez et les
téléphones que vous avez aujourd'hui et
c'est cette vitesse là qui vous permet
d'avoir accès à de l'information d'un
claquement de doigts c'est cette vitesse
là qui vous donne l'impression d'être
connecté au monde entier juste en une
fraction de seconde de casser les
barrières et de vous ouvrir des millions
de possibilités et encore une fois à
côté de ça pour avoir justement cette
vitesse dont on a tant besoin
aujourd'hui les industriels ont besoin
d'extraire des matériaux de plus
plus rare et le nombre croissant
d'internautes ne va pas arranger la
situation
oui le numérique a malheureusement un
impact écologique très très forts dont
je pense vous avez tous entendu parler
aujourd'hui
il est urgent si nous voulons garder le
confort qui a été amené par le numérique
quand j'entends confort je veux dire
regardez nos séries en streaming sur
netflix par exemple ça c'est confortable
ça aurait jamais été possible avec
autant de vitesse derrière on se rend
compte aujourd'hui qu'on a un impact
comment garder notre confort tout en
réduisant notre impact écologique
c'est un sujet de premier ordre qu'il
faut vraiment traité si nous voulons
pouvoir continuer à utiliser le
numérique
selon ses usages cinquième et dernier
point la communication vous êtes les
premiers à pouvoir témoigner de sa
constamment connecté à vos amis vos
familles où vous soyez dans le monde
vous pouvez rester en contact avec vos
proches moi-même pendant mon voyage au
17 mois j'en ai grandement profité j'ai
appelé ma famille maman toutes les deux
semaines quand même faut pas sinon cette
enquête rester en contact très très
franche avec nos amis et ça encore une
fois j'insiste c'est formidable c'est
réellement une chose dont on ne pourrait
plus se passer aujourd'hui
en même temps il est tellement facile de
se couper du monde extérieur de se
mettre dans sa bulle de ne plus faire
attention aux personnes autour de nous
je pense que vous faites aussi des
soirées parfois vous prenez deux minutes
pour faire une pause et vous voyez tout
le monde un peu son téléphone portable
n'oublions pas que l'humain se nourrit
d'interaction sociale et que s'ils ne
voulons pas perdre notre humanité
ce qui nous rend humain il important de
raisonner nos usages du numérique
j'espère qu'ils avaient qu'à travers les
propos que je vous ai que qu'à amener
mon raisonnement aujourd'hui que cela
aura attiser votre curiosité que vous
aurez envie d'en apprendre plus de vous
renseigner
nous sommes tous acteurs de cette
révolution et j'avoue avoir un double
sentiment à la fois d'excitation parce
que c'est la première révolution que je
vis vous et en même temps d'appréhension
parce que je ne sais pas ce que l'avenir
nous réserve mais je suis certain que
nous saurons rendre brillant comment
comment est ce qu'on peut faire
je suis convaincu que chacun à son
niveau nous pouvons agir pour ma part je
me concentre principalement sur les
aspects écologiques du numérique
c'est quelque chose qui me tient à coeur
et ça passe par énormément de recherches
est beaucoup de sensibilisation tout
comme rome ne s'est pas construite en un
jour il est impossible d'avoir un rayon
d'action qui va impacter l'ensemble des
thèmes que j'ai abordé aujourd'hui et si
vous vous deviez en choisir un
sur lequel vous concentrez lequel
propose 17 choisiriez vous choisiriez
vous lequel choisirez vous avant de vous
quitter
une vraie conclut par cette phrase la
révolution numérique
elle est ni bonne ni mauvaise allez
simplement ce que nous déciderons
d'enfer merci beaucoup pour votre
attention
[Applaudissements]